once again as a public service to this  year's Comic Con attendees here are some  panels this weekend if you're interested  that have very very short lines you'll  get in you'll get out on Sunday there's  a game of Thrones Starbucks cup shares  its next project yeah yeah yeah then  there's a Chernobyl and all Amish  production of the HBO hit Chernobyl  there's yeah right  there's learn to make sausages with Vin  Diesel stunt double Clegg mantle yeah  there's the folding tables from  comic-con 1982 still folding after all  these years  hey check this one out margot robbie  ignores you in a hotel elevator I can't  believe nobody's going it out they're  going to that yeah hey check this out  George Lucas's passion project his  unaired pert plus commercials yeah right  and finally Andy Richter will silently  scowl at you for 45 minutes  that's just a little taste well chase  yeah I'm scared you have to chant my  name but the minute I try and get him to  do my bidding they all chickened out